can i tell you something i'm bad at
i am terrible at making click bait
up until two years ago my most popular
video was about a basketball being
dropped from a dam with a bit of
backspin
it takes off like a rocket and shoots
out way further than you'd expect
this video was embedded on literally
hundreds of news websites and in its
first week it got 16.3
million views but almost none of those
views came on the youtube platform
why because i gave it this thumbnail and
i called it strange applications of the
magnus effect
this video is sponsored by kiwico more
about them at the end of the show
now i believe within youtube i'm used as
an example of how not to package your
video as if to demonstrate just how bad
a title and thumbnail this is someone
else re-uploaded the video with a clever
title basketball dropped from damn
and within a few weeks that video had
received tens of millions of views on
youtube this is when youtube gave me
access to content id that's the system
that allows you to earn revenue when
someone else re-uploads your videos
which was good but i still wasn't very
good at click bait so for this video i
called in an expert
i wanted to see your reaction face can
you give me like a reaction face like
what's a good thumbnail face oh i got
you this is a thumbnail face
i i have like 10 i go through the
motions of like
let me just take the best one i probably
have like 500 of these just saved and we
can just photoshop my face on my face i
don't really have to do it anymore
when i started on this platform some 10
years ago click bait was less important
subscribers were what mattered because
most of the views came from the subfeed
and videos went viral usually by getting
a lot of attention elsewhere like on
reddit or facebook not due to the
youtube algorithm but once you had a big
video and people subscribed well then
your next video would likely get a lot
of views from those subscribers so
youtube would take that popular video
and share it with more people and so you
get more subscribers in a positive
feedback loop
but soon youtube realized that this did
not create the best experience for the
viewer they discovered that showing
people only videos from channels they
were subscribed to led to fewer clicks
less watch time and less engagement with
the site as a whole plus they knew that
relying on other platforms to drive
traffic to viral hits was risky since
those other platforms might disable the
traffic at any time so they needed to
make youtube a destination in itself
they wanted people to come to youtube
see videos that interested them click on
at least one of them and watch it for a
while ideally get sucked down the
youtube rabbit hole and spend hours on
the site without even noticing it the
ultimate resource is people's time and
attention and every platform is trying
to capture as much of it as possible so
to make youtube this go-to destination
they had to decrease the importance of
subscribers make it less like a podcast
app where you only get the shows you're
subscribed to and more like reddit where
stuff with the most engagement rises to
the top but that necessarily meant
increasing the importance of clickbait
now there seems to be a paradox when it
comes to click bait people almost
universally claim to hate it
but you also see it everywhere so why is
this well one of the problems is we
don't all agree on the definition of
click bait when i google it the top
definition is on the internet content
whose main purpose is to attract
attention and encourage visitors to
click on a link to a particular web page
we could call this type one click bait
and there doesn't seem to be anything
wrong with it i mean if you didn't try
to attract attention and get people to
click on your links then you wouldn't
really be doing your job but there is a
second definition one that i think more
people ascribe to which is something
such as a headline designed to make
readers want to click on a hyperlink
especially when the link leads to
content of dubious value or interest
wikipedia says a defining characteristic
of clickbait is that it is
sensationalized or misleading and it
also talks about teasers that
intentionally withhold information to
exploit the curiosity gap they give you
enough information to make you curious
but not enough to satisfy that curiosity
here are two actual titles from a news
website 9 out of 10 americans are
completely wrong about this mind-blowing
fact
and someone gave some kids some scissors
here's what happened next
i think we can all agree that these are
examples of bad type 2 clickbait now
imagine a click bait space where on one
axis you have how misleading or
sensationalized it is and on the other
how much information is intentionally
withheld to create a curiosity gap well
then these two titles fall in the top
right corner and these are the zones of
type 2 clickbait at the other extreme
you have things that are so
unsensationalized as to be dull you
could call this the dead zone
now here is where you would find strange
applications of the magnus effect i mean
i didn't tell you what the applications
were
now in the middle is where you would
find type 1 click bait but honestly i
think type 1 and type 2 click bait are
so different that we shouldn't even use
the same word for them instead of type 1
clickbait my friend and youtuber brady
herron suggested legit bait i mean it
might sound enticing but it is legit
instead of type 2 clickbait we could use
click trap click trick link trap or dupe
shoot
what's important to recognize is that
for any given video there is no one true
title and thumbnail each video could
have hundreds or thousands of different
legit bait titles for example how does a
zero g plane work i went on a plane that
does parabolic trajectories what happens
to fire on a zero g plane
now the most enticing titles and
thumbnails are found close to type 2
click bait i'm reminded of the
infographic by smarter every day showing
that on social media the greatest
engagement occurs close to the boundary
of what's allowable but remember that
everyone's definition of click bait is
different and everyone's perceptions of
words and images are different so these
are not clear boundaries they're
actually kind of fuzzy
what for one person might be legit bait
for someone else could be a click trap
what's clear is that on a site where
click-through rate is important
clickbait of all types is inevitable how
important to a video success is the
title and thumbnail very important of
course if they don't click on the video
they don't watch it you can't get 10
million views unless 10 billion people
click on the video so
it's literally that simple they don't
click on it they don't watch it so why
is click bait everywhere
well because it works
more enticing thumbnails get more clicks
despite some people's claims that they
won't click or they'll unsub it's just
like evolution whatever survives
multiplies and traits become amplified
if you don't begrudge the giraffe it's
long neck so it can reach the highest
leaves can you begrudge a youtuber the
big red arrow that allows them to reach
further audiences
i talked about this in my video two
years ago to be successful as a youtuber
you need to optimize two things watch
time and the click-through rate of your
videos that's the number of times the
title and thumbnail are clicked divided
by the total number of times they're
shown that's the number of impressions
now at the time this was something of a
revelation for me because i always
thought my job was to make great videos
and then a title and thumbnail that
adequately represented what the video
was about but now i've realized that
making the title and thumbnail is at
least half the job
this is not just because better titles
and thumbnails get you more clicks but
because better titles and thumbnails
will get you way more impressions
youtube has limited real estate with
which to show you virtually infinite
content and so it's not enough to make a
good video even if people watch all of
it you also have to make a title and
thumbnail that gets clicked especially
in competition with other really good
titles and thumbnails that's the only
way you can expect youtube to give you
more impressions
now the big development since my last
video on this is youtube introduced
real-time metrics like views impressions
and click-through rate now i suggested
this would create an arms race so what
you can bet will happen is that creators
will launch a video and then they'll be
sitting there with all these different
variants of thumbnails and they'll be
swapping them out and looking at what
that does to click-through rate and then
going with the one that leads to the
greatest click-through rate and this is
basically what has happened let me give
you my favorite example
last year i made a video about asteroids
which i thought was really good i called
it asteroids earth's biggest threat
which is something stephen hawking said
and people were very positive about the
video they thought it was maybe one of
my best but the performance was well
below average in its first day asteroids
was ranked ninth out of my previous 10
videos it was probably on target for
about one and a half million views
so i tried different titles and
thumbnails like asteroid impact what are
our chances or asteroid impact what
could we do
but none of these changes got much
traction and then on day three after
lunch i changed the title and thumbnail
to
these are the asteroids to worry about
and immediately the video started doing
better it quickly shot up from almost my
worst performing video to my best it now
has 14 million views
nothing about the video changed just
that one image and 38 characters but
because of that the video has reached
nearly 10 times as many people as it
otherwise would have and the title and
thumbnail accurately describe what the
video is about i mean sure there's a
curiosity gap but you couldn't explain
the whole concept in the length of the
title
so if you see a youtuber changing titles
and thumbnails this is why because that
effort can be rewarded many times over
i've seen people objecting to this
practice because they think the creator
is trying to dupe their audience get
them to click on the same video more
than once but that's not it
the whole point is to get youtube to
show the title and thumbnail to more
people we're trying to increase the
number of impressions which is heavily
dependent on the click-through rate
now a lot of my recent videos have this
typical view curve there's an initial
spike after i release the video and then
a dip and then a second bump after i
have figured out a better title and
thumbnail i change the title and
thumbnail and i watch the real-time view
graph what i'm looking for is a
noticeable bump in views sometimes
there's no change sometimes it gets
worse but on occasions when you see
something like this well then you know
you've found a winner
this is something all the big youtubers
are doing not even mr beast knows
exactly which thumbnail will work best
beforehand have you ever changed the
title and thumbnail and then the video
did better oh of course
so every video i usually make like two
or three thumbnails and then if it's not
doing as well as i want we usually just
swap them out and see if it does better
um it's the thing is like you don't
really know
i mean you could know if you just were
an almighty being that could just
predict what people would be interested
in but uh you know usually like you do
hide and seek you don't really know if
like you hiding in a tree and then
someone walking below you is a good
thumbnail or if you're hiding in a trash
can and then walking in front of you so
you know just do both and then see which
one interests people a little bit more i
feel the same way but i i do feel like
you have a better sense of this than
like most people of course i mean no one
gets 40 million views a video
but what is the point in getting more
views
if you're cynical you might say it's all
about money and fame and while there are
certainly financial incentives to
getting more views that's not why i do
it as an educational youtuber i think
there are two very good reasons for
using excellent type 1 clickbait over
more straightforward packaging to
understand the first reason let's
consider two different possible titles
for my most recent video i called it the
simplest math problem no one can solve
but it's a video about the collats
conjecture so perhaps a more
straightforward title would have been
simply to call it that
the problem is if i publish a video
called the call-outs conjecture the most
likely people to click on it are those
who already know what the call-outs
conjecture is and the vast majority of
people will never have heard of it so
for them the title is meaningless and
only the very curious or those who
really like veritasium would click
in contrast calling it the simplest math
problem no one can solve conveys more
information about the video to everyone
and this means more people can click on
it most of whom will never have heard of
the call-outs conjecture so i get to
teach them something new
and since the video has a higher
click-through rate youtube shows it to
even more people
so if my aim is to increase the level of
knowledge in the world by the maximum
amount possible
this is the way to do it
the second reason we need to optimize
titles and thumbnails is to support the
major goal of this channel we are trying
to make the best science films on every
topic we tackle that means traveling to
meet experts and film experiments hiring
people to build props make spectacular
animations research and fact check we
hire expert consultants to double and
triple check our work
i don't want to make vlogs i want to
make science documentaries on youtube
that put broadcast to shame and to make
this possible and sustainable the videos
have to get views and lots of them and
to do that we have to make the best
titles and thumbnails we can
youtuber and patreon ceo jack conti has
talked about adjusting your packaging
the idea is know what you're passionate
about what you won't compromise on and
that stuff goes in the box all the rest
like what paper it's wrapped in that's
the packaging so the video is my focus
and the title and thumbnail are the
packaging that i'm happy to adjust so i
can make the type of videos that are
important to me now is it ironic that a
channel whose whole purpose is to
promote a true seeking mindset has to
experiment at the edge of what is
truthful in order to fulfill that
purpose
it is something that i often worry about
you know when i did like risk in my life
to
do x it's like well what probability of
death does there have to be for you to
risk your life like fifty percent i
don't know he always overthinks things
that's funny he's like is my life risked
enough where i could put irish my life
you know i only had a nine percent
chance of dying and i need at least a 13
chance he is so funny he was the same
way two years ago when he asked me all
this stuff i was like dude just do
whatever makes the most sense yeah i
mean obviously like i feel like my
instincts are not good but what i
realized is that i don't have to trust
my instincts this problem of getting the
best title and thumbnail it's a
scientific problem
we're just asking which accurate
representation of the video will get the
most clicks from a general audience and
that's a problem we can use the
scientific method to solve so i've hired
a couple of really bright people and we
spend a lot of time brainstorming and
making titles and thumbnails and testing
them out for example on twitter and
patreon veritasium titles and thumbnails
have gotten better not because i'm
better at it but because of my team and
our testing
if you have ideas about how we could do
it better please get in touch the
results have often contradicted what i
expected i mean this video seemed to
perform 10 percent better when we
excluded the word surprising from the
title so it became simply the secret of
synchronization
i thought these two titles were
basically a toss-up but patreon had a
strong preference for one over the other
what's interesting about this research
is that the more clickable titles and
thumbnails often better represent the
content of the video let me give you
some examples you know one thing i
didn't expect when youtube brought in
the real-time analytics tools and
allowed title and thumbnail changes to
affect impressions was that it would
also work for older videos so here is an
old video that i originally entitled why
the neutron is the hero of nuclear
physics
in hindsight it's a weird kind of
meaningless title so i changed it to why
einstein thought nuclear weapons
impossible it's clearer more accurate
and this is what happened to views after
the change
i changed strange applications of the
magnus effect to backspin basketball
flies off damn again more accurate and
the video is now being watched on
youtube
probably 10 million more views than it
otherwise would have had even anti-click
bait has proven effective here's a video
i originally titled are negative ions
good for you which is a question nobody
asked ever
now i changed it to do salt lamps work
seriously
and here's the result
one and a half million more views
i think looking at these examples you
could easily make the case that youtube
has made me better at what i do it has
improved the clarity and accuracy of my
titles and thumbnails it's helped me
figure out what is interesting to my
audience and how to encapsulate that in
a single image in fewer than 50
characters
for those of you who worry that a focus
on titles and thumbnails will prevent me
from picking challenging science topics
well i simply ask you to look at the
videos from the last year or two like
the ones on google's incompleteness
theorem general relativity penrose
tilings the logistic map newton's method
of calculating pi the one-way speed of
light
good titles and thumbnails make it
possible to tackle these topics and to
reach more people who have never heard
of them before
there is a symbiotic relationship
between views and video quality the more
views we get the more people locations
props and equipment and research we can
invest in
this makes the next video better than
the last
if we can be good at titles and
thumbnails the ultimate outcome is
better videos that is something i think
you and i both want
hey this video is sponsored by kiwiko a
longtime supporter of the channel now
kiwico makes awesome hands-on projects
for kids including big kids like me they
have eight subscription lines targeted
at different age groups all the way down
to newborns what i love about kiwico
crates is that they make learning fun
and something to look forward to i mean
when i pull out a crate my kids just
jump at the chance to make it with me
and all the materials you need come
right in the box so there's no need to
run to the store you just open it up and
go my kids and i just built this domino
machine which who knows might be
inspiration for a viral video now the
big idea is that while playing and
having fun kids learn about steam
concepts that is science technology
engineering art and math and in addition
to the project there's a magazine with a
lot of additional information so i think
this is the best way to learn by doing
something yourself and having fun it's
how education should be so if you want
to try it out go to kiwico.com
veritasium50 and you'll get 50 off your
first month of any crate i will put that
link down in the description so i want
to thank kiwiko for sponsoring
veritasium and i want to thank you for
watching